le département de la réunion récompense
les lauréats du concours du plus beau
collège fleury pour cette troisième
édition
c'est le collège titans qui remporte le
premier prix
ces collégiens se sont investis dans
l'amélioration de leur environnement
scolaire en proposant une association
harmonieuse et durable du minéral et du
végétal
alors ce bateau en bois de goyavier
c'est une idée qui a germé dans notre
esprit pour pour créer à dès l'entrée de
l'établissement
un symbole qui rappelle à tous
la situation de notre établissement le
port donc rappeler notre environnement
la mer les pêcheurs
donc c'est un une barque en bois de
goyavier qui fait office de jardinières
alors ce genre d'actions permet
effectivement l'embellissement des
collèges et aussi permettre au coi à
l'ensemble de nos collégiens d'avoir un
cadre de vie qui est correct et bien ce
que nous et là se sent bien là où il
souhaite bien sûr s'épanouir et
s'instruire au total vingt
établissements soit près de 1500 élèves
de toute l'île ont fait le choix d'être
les acteurs de leur vie collégienne
le deuxième prix revient au collège
albert lougnon de saint paul pour la
réalisation d'une fresque sur la façade
de leur établissement évolué avec la
prof d'arts plastiques faire une fresque
sur les bâtiments de sciences ou tu as
qui représentait le paysage de la
réunion débat vers les eaux donc avec la
savane avec paysages des forêts
organique
les forêts des eaux la végétation
alimentaire au niveau 2 du volcan ça a
été un très très gros travail d'art
plastique
les agents nous ont beaucoup aidés à
faire au niveau des finitions au niveau
de la peinture au niveau du fond les
élèves de tous niveaux que ce soit de la
6e à la 3e ont aidé au niveau du
fleurissement du collège espère à ce
concours départemental investi les
collégiens dans l'amélioration de leur
environnement scolaire un projet avant
tout pédagogique qui réunit les
enseignants les collégiens ainsi que les
équipes du département
on a travaillé avec et pour essayer les
élèves et j'ai remarqué que la lune un
engouement aussi au niveau des élèves de
pouvoir planter et connaître les noms
des plantes et où d'ailleurs il savait
même pas ces noms là ils étaient surpris
d'avoir deux d'avoir ces plantes à ses
yeux et sans connaître le nom
là tu appris de choses mais j'ai appris
les noms de fleurs
je ne savais pas quelles étaient les
plus encore des milk de la réunion c'est
bien ça embellit le collège bain par
exemple qu'on avait c'est une fresque
sociale d'hésiter avant le mur il était
blanc s'était pas trop c'est trop beau à
voir mais là c'est la cic coloré sens
mieux et on a fait aussi des amis des
petites plantations c'est bien on s'est
tous investi le troisième prix revient
au collège bois de nèfles à saint denis
pour ces aménagements réalisés à
l'entrée de l'établissement